the health care, for example
with medicines in greece is
not secured at the moment and
therefore europe has to make sure in any case
that the ordinary people don't pay the
bitter price for the wrong policy
of super it now
europe has to help the people but be
tough with the government
they are  now responsible for
describing how we got out of this blockade
situation in europe
i believe that the liquidity
problems in greece are the problems
that urgently need to be solved
i do not believe
in working in greece with an alternative currency
i still believe that it would be the right thing to do in
greece  to stay in the euro zone
we want to make it clear that
negotiations are taking place but it must not always
be at our expense we
want reforms to be possible but they
must not only be at our
expense and were primarily
those with the lowest
incomes  available  Does the next moment in
east rowling events business summit of
european leaders in brussels